[Music]
adolescent Sheldon Cooper isn't as young
as he once was come season seven it
might be time for young Sheldon's
showrunners to hang up the towel as a
spin-off from one of the most widely
maimed sitcoms of the 21st century snide
comments about the existence of young
Sheldon have gotten older than the
series star itself at this point they're
also fairly unwarranted as this is
consistently one of the highest rated
Network hits on TV however the very
title of young Sheldon implies the
series can't expand as endlessly as its
parent program The Big Bang Theory and
in fact when we look at the larger
narrative we're rapidly approaching the
point where he will finally age up and
not be considered young anymore for this
reason we believe the seventh season of
the series should Mark the end of the
sitcom's run as regular viewers of the
spin-off series will recall adult
Sheldon confirmed his father's premature
death through voiceover at the end of
season 4 and it seems that the entire
Show's trajectory is starting to evolve
more toward that inevitable life event
event while the events were long passed
in the time the Big Bang Theory takes
place this loss is going to hit a lot
harder now that viewers have spent six
seasons getting to know Sheldon's father
George in fact George is such a major
character in the series it's quite
possible his death will be so
devastating that the showrunners may
need to call it quits just to preserve
the show's Legacy we've already caught a
glimpse of the emotional weight his
character's Health carries after his
heart attack in season one George's
physical well-being isn't the only
aspect of his character the show is
zeroing in on throughout season 5 George
also begins developing an interesting
relationship with his recently divorced
neighbor Brenda while conflict with his
own wife bruise under the surface who
knew you were so handy yeah it's just
things guys need to be good at what else
he good at the simmering pot begins to
Bubble when Mary gets a new job at the
local bar with Brenda and she learns
that Brenda has a secret love interest
the tension built further when in season
six Sheldon's sister reveals that
Brendan's son that caught George and her
alone together with so much
foreshadowing toward this plot point an
official confirmation of the affair
seems inevitable with all this tension
built and various other members of the
family also experiencing Milestones
throughout its run season six has taken
many of the narrative turns of a typical
sitcom's penultimate season which only
solidifies the fact that it would make
perfect sense to round things out with
one final season another important
factor to consider about the
significance of George's passing and
infidelity is the effect it will
inevitably have on Sheldon it's possible
that losing his father or the inevitable
trauma that will ensue in the Cooper
household when Georges Affair gets out
May turn out to be the Catalyst for
adult Sheldon's difficulties with
emotional intelligence childhood traumas
like these would well inform Sheldon's
lack of trust and intimacy which he
slowly overcomes with Amy throughout the
Big Bang Theory it also indicates the
end of a fairly complacent era for the
famously complicated Cooper family
what's more we already have some insight
into how Sheldon reacts to these events
and the season 11 episode of The Big
Bang Theory The Sibling realignment in
adult George confronts Sheldon for
leaving home so soon after their
father's death he rightfully calls him
out for being selfish as their family
was in pieces after George's passing
George had to step up and take care of
his mother and sister on top of his own
family while Sheldon moved out to
California for graduate school once
Sheldon leaves home it will be almost
impossible to consider him a child these
life-changing events will make him seem
older while also adding a few thousand
miles between him and his family after
this it's hard to imagine how the show
could continue past season 7 without
defying its basic premise season 6 has
also been a palette cleanser from
Sheldon's know-it-all Antics which
usually hog the center Spotlight with
George's baby mama drama fans have even
started calling for a spin-off this is
an intriguing idea to keep the series
alive though it will definitely need to
Veer away from its young Sheldon title a
spin-off of a spin-off isn't an unheard
of concept either even if they are a bit
rare in this form we could still see Ian
Armitage as the brilliant young grad
student through guest appearances or
even over the phone this format has
already been tested on the series with
Jim Parsons reprising his role as adult
Sheldon via narration the timing
couldn't be better either with the
family mourning the loss of their
patriarch and adjusting to life without
Sheldon around the main focus could
easily shift to Georgie and Mandy's new
little one while we certainly don't want
to say goodbye to George's character the
show's been hinting at its fate since
the jump and it's finally time to throw
the dart at the bullseye
thank you